bonjour moment d'opérer je déménage mais
pourquoi tu ne m'installes pas dans
l'appartement de l'avenue fausses j'ai
envie de me débrouiller tout seul
est-ce que j'aurais apprécié c'est que
tu me dises un jour la vérité je suis au
courant pour ça il le prof de tennis tu
penses que je suis pas ton fils avec
l'a4 que tu as hélas le droit d'aborder
d'autres quand même tu fais quoi dans la
vie toi je travaille dans une banque
c'est bon ça il est banquier comme toi
tu es pilote d'avion t ou faux quoi a
vanté pilote d'avion en fait rachid
pizzas kebabs au quartier ils cherchent
qu'un cas pour le pilote du coup de main
ben moi je le fais vas-y tu commences
domaine charles la france avait passé la
rampe
oui c'est bon je vais pas en afghanistan
là c'est pire c'est nouveau dans le
quartier toi mais tu t'appelles comment
mohamed doit shoah j'ai menti sur mon
ange manière j'ai une tête de bouchons
renseigne-toi sources nomades je n'aime
pas les mecs qui sortent de l'ombre à
métro le découle man
ok ce cas merci
je sais pas ce qui m'arrive elle me rend
dingue cette halte harper que si tu pars
à laroque mohamed juillard à l'aller à
la lll à la laine
papa maman salam aleikoum annoncé quoi
cette façon de parler
si un trend la vérité du livre autres
moi-même bouchoucha c'est ça
sur le coran de la mecque je m'appelle
arnaud dubois
[Musique]
ferrari
musique c'est super boulot et qu'ils
adoptent un robot jeunes apprennent le
chinois comme ça ils savent qui va bien
bosser à l'école tu vois
[Musique]
m